once this was lush Amazon rainforest one
of the most biodiverse areas on the
planet NOW has been reduced to ashes
cleared most probably to make way for
cattle ranches new data from Brazilian
authorities shows the rate of
deforestation has increased by a third
over the last year to almost ten
thousand square kilometers that's an
area equivalent to three football
pitches being lost every minute we've
already lost 20% of the Amazon
rainforest and scientific analysis shows
that if we lose just another 5% the
Amazon rainforest reaches a tipping
point it becomes arid it can't sustain
itself any longer and we lose it it'll
become savanna and without the Amazon
rainforest
we cannot tackle climate change at a
global level deforestation rates in the
Brazilian Amazon fell from almost twenty
eight thousand square kilometers in 2004
to a low of just four and a half
thousand in 2012 a conservation success
story but in the year to July it rose to
just over nine thousand seven hundred
square kilometers that's the highest
rate in 11 years you're in Brazil now
what have you seen when you go to the
Amazon that backs up what these figures
show having shows that the the current
policies of the Brazilian government
which are to to undermine environmental
monitoring and to underfund and reduce
the funding of environmental agencies
has led to a feeling that people can
DeForest with impunity
the figures undermine claims by
Brazilian President Jaya bolson ro the
deforestation rates are normal
crops and cattle from deforested areas
are entering the global food supply
chain WWF urged Britain's political
leaders to commit to a ban on the
produce reducing the incentive to burn
down the Amazon Thomas More Sky News